do you think this video will be on the
internet in 2070
maybe in some internet archive somewhere
well researchers of the future if you
were wondering what we were doing here
in the 2020s about climate change the
answer is we were committing to Net Zero
in the past few years more than 70
countries one after the next have made a
pledge to reach net zero emissions that
includes places that have barely
contributed to climate warming and it
includes all of the countries that have
been most responsible for emissions so
far
it seems like everyone got the message
that humankind needs to become carbon
neutral and we need to do it in the next
three to five decades
but that would have been easier if we
had started cutting emissions 20 years
ago because now we're up here and the
math is getting really tough so to make
it work governments are penciling in
negative emissions
that's the net part of the Net Zero
promise the idea that we can reach zero
while still emitting greenhouse gases if
we're also taking CO2 out of the air
it's a bit contentious but we're going
to be hearing a lot about it it's called
CDR so carbon dioxide removal what we
want to do is put that carbon back where
it belongs Gianna Amador is a CDR
Advocate and she's going to help us
explain this with the bathtub metaphor
the bathtub in the situation is our
atmosphere and the water in the bathtub
is the CO2 that's in our atmosphere
before the Industrial Revolution the
land and ocean typically released as
much CO2 into the air as they absorbed
back down through this drain but when
people started digging up coal and oil
to power their machines first in Europe
and then in the U.S it sent this new
flow of CO2 into the air one that the
plants and oceans couldn't keep up with
about 45 percent of those emissions stay
in the atmosphere trapping heat and
setting us up for an escalating array of
climate disasters
so in 2015 all of the countries sent
someone off to Paris to say okay
everyone we need to keep warming well
below 2 degrees Celsius and really we're
aiming for 1.5 degrees that's above
pre-industrial levels and the exact
numbers matter less than the fact that
every increment of warming increases
risk so first and foremost we need to
turn off the top everything else is
futile if we don't stop the root of the
problem today turn off that top stop
emitting CO2
not only have we not turned off any Taps
Global emissions are still Rising
especially in Asia where you know 60 of
human beings live many of whom are just
emerging out of poverty so now we're
here at nearly 1.2 degrees of warming
frankly we have not done what it would
take to meet that 1.5 degree goal
but we may be able to keep warming under
two degrees if all of those Net Zero
promises become real Net Zero policies
and that's where things get a little
tricky
turning these emissions all the way off
could get really hard really expensive
or even unfair so everyone's kind of
hoping that we can work from the bottom
of the tub too to kind of increase the
size of the drain increase the speed in
which we can drain that water from the
bathtub now CDR is distinct from CCS
which prevents emissions at the source
that works on the faucet CDR grabs CO2
from the air and people have come up
with a lot of interesting ways of doing
that the most common one so far is
planting and protecting forests it's one
of the more affordable CDR approaches
right now and it has a lot of benefits
aside from capturing CO2 but we've seen
from problems with the carbon offsets
Market that it can be hard to verify and
you know trees don't live forever so
most of the modeling scenarios that
limit warming assume will also be able
to build a new drain for more permanent
carbon storage
so through things like rot weathering we
can crush up a bunch of rocks that
naturally react with CO2 and try to
speed up that reaction or we can use
chemistry to mimic natural processes
through Technologies like director
capture which basically use a type of
chemical that selectively binds with CO2
to capture it from the air these
techniques all come with different costs
and they're in really early stages of
development so there's a concern that
the people in charge of the faucets will
see any movement down here as an excuse
to avoid making Cuts up there
should we be counting on large amounts
of carbon removal for our climate plans
well it seems we already are
the US government's Net Zero plan calls
for 500 million metric tons of CO2
removal by 2050 up from zero today model
simulations that limit warming to 1.5
degrees Envision around 3.8 billion tons
of permanent carbon removal globally
every year
and this is the total amount of
permanent carbon removal that has
happened so far
so would you call that wishful thinking
or is it foresight about how much can
happen in 30 years if we start our way
up the learning curve now we have
actually a really strong Playbook of
developing Technologies and driving down
costs if we go all the way back to the
1970s we see Technologies like solar PV
be around 70 per watt fast forward to
2023 we see those prices down at around
seven cents per watt or even lower and
at Price parity with fossil fuels the
challenge with that is that is that
renewable energy produces something
that's quite useful which is energy and
CDR
what is the customer for cdrs or what
where does the demand come from you've
seen some major companies including
stripe meta alphabet McKinsey Microsoft
all of these companies have made
commitments to purchase carbon dioxide
removal as part of their Corporate
social responsibility plans that being
said I think in the long term carbon
removal could be provided as a public
service in the ways that we manage some
of our other pollution we pay for
someone to come around to collect our
trash and to manage it in a way that
it's safe for our communities
the US government is already offering
billions of dollars to try to get a
direct air capture industry off the
ground and I think it makes sense for
the countries that have used the most
fossil fuels to do the work of finding
out if CDR can scale
but if it doesn't
well then Net Zero will have been just
another way of kicking the can down the
road which of course is how we ended up
here in the first place in this position
where we may now have no choice
but to try everything
[Music]
foreign